[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
at android studio we have built
expertise on strategy games with titles
such as endless space
endless legend and more recently
humankind
when we released it in 2014 dungeon of
the endless was our first
venture into the roguelike juan a unique
mix of strategy
action and rpg mechanics never seen
before
[Music]
in dungeon of the endless the player has
to protect the generator
of his crashed ship while exploring an
almost infinite dungeon
all while facing waves of monsters as he
tries to find his way out
[Music]
the game ended up winning a lot of
awards for its game design
and shall we say captured the hearts of
both amplitude fans
and roguelike fans but even knowing this
we didn't really expect such an
enthusiastic reaction when we revealed
the next game
endless dungeon at the game awards in
december 2020
endless dungeon is the return of
amplitude on the roguelike scene a genre
we like a lot
the game is a spiritual sequel of the
original dungeon of the endless keeping
the core pillars of the game
all while proposing a whole new
experience for fans and new players
alike
now because of the first game's success
we knew the formula was loved by players
but we were still seeing a lot of
potential and new ideas to explore
i remember exactly how the product
started
we're all together having like a big
party at amplitude to celebrate
something i have no idea what it was and
we had a lot of beer
and someone came with the idea of you
know and
and what if we made our own
so for the first time we had the product
validated uh it may be like five days
you know um
after like
you know and and that's that's an
amazing moment that's yeah pretty much
how it
started now the player will still have
to escort the crystal using the hero
skills plus
weapons turrets and a good dose of good
thinking
to be able to make it all the way to the
exit the heroes will also be more
important than ever in endless dungeon
as you'll be able to unlock and recruit
a bunch of colorful characters
each one with their specificity special
attacks their biography and backgrounds
and the way they react to events in the
dungeon we've already discovered four of
them in the previous trailers now but i
know everyone's asking
will the pug be there well we know she'd
love to be there
we'll have to see what happens
[Music]
we also believe that no one should go on
a seemingly hopeless mission alone so
endless dungeon is meant to be playable
either solo or with your friends in
co-op we hope to deliver a great co-op
experience so you can explore the
dungeon with your friends
we would also like to step up the
community engagement a notch
frequently proposing votes on our games
together platform
this will allow players to directly
impact the game by voting on various
topics such as lore gameplay
and concepts and as always giving
feedback to the dev team
player feedback has always been crucial
to the way we make games so keep an eye
out for opportunities to try the game
and let us know what you think
the community already chose that
official name and the creeper's name
so now we have so much more coming for
you on games together so you can
participate to the production of endless
dungeon
so sign up to games together to stay in
the loop cast your votes and make your
voice heard